[Music]
Salam alikum guys hope you're are doing
fine uh basically the video will start
really shortly uh basically I went to O
circus last night and came across some
black Israelites and basically I just
wanted to find out what they believe and
also wanted to do daah and talk about
you know why I believe the prophet
mhammad peace be upon his mentioned in
the bible Etc obviously didn't go as
peaceful as I wanted to you know they
got a bit aggressive they even called me
names swearing and stuff like that the
reason I went there is basically to show
you viewers out there who's you know
interested in da as well you're going to
come across these kind of stuff a lot
you know you have to be patient keep
your cool you know you're doing the
right thing you're on the HW you know
and Allah says when truthful is spoken
falsehood perishes and you will see in
the video inshallah and that was my
purpose to be honest if anything I said
wrong is from myself and Shan and
anything good is obviously from Allah
tala please enjoy the video and
[Music]
subscribe I think you're [__] I think
you're that's good
man why we why do we have to get violent
why do we have to get
violent what I'm trying to say to you I
come here did I say anything
disrespectful to you guys
know the Bible says the Bible says
whoever
despises I didn't despise
list bro bro listen did I come here and
disrespect any of you guys I
came I asked questions and I want no but
you asked it with an evil mind so if you
going to understand the answer you going
to understand the question if you don't
understand the question
go look I'm okay with it if you guys are
cool with it I'm okay with it look I'll
take it look I'm telling you I'm okay
with this I'm okay with I
know hey bro we're not really being
violent man we have not yet begun to be
violent oh when we get violent we going
to put the Bibles down man
what's heads are going to roll BR heads
are going roll all right man we can roll
it can I say something does the parable
say you ask God and God forgives yes or
no of course okay I'm asking you where
does Jesus Come into by him dying
because you have to ask in his name he's
the
intercessor was so he could become the
intercessor so we have a channel to ask
the most but why does it talk about that
channel because it doesn't need
to done
just he said something and you know
start dancing bro
188 read again read again I will raise
them on the Propet from among their
rever that's it it's done we're done
done you you
wait wait wait the Hebrew word of
reverence no let's get the Hebrew word
of
even myself one voice we're answering
the question they didn't finish reading
the verse no wait let's get the Hebrew
word I'm giving you this as well let's
give you the Hebrew word for preference
okay
h251 H yeah H what does it mean bro it
means brother brother
of same parents yeah relative kingship
same
[Music]
tribe each to the
other um who
wait
you're not you're not going to jump
after
finish there you go same tribe that's
your bre not
is you know to
insult insult I can't
insult evil your same God promised him
man your
God promised
him God prom right promised you're
hating someone you're hating someone
that you're god promise promise what
promise
what how is the nation fruitful by
having Cars oil
sand
aever being aever days man of the body
is
children with this guy that's Christians
1 plus
one stay away from Islam
[__] out look let me let me read it
again a prophet from among their
Brethren
you
wait [__] hold
on why was he like what in what way was
he going to be like onto Moses in what
way was he going to be like onto Moses
can I ask you a question what way was he
going to be who's God talking about huh
who's God talking about here yah to the
who's the Moses okay who's going to be
like him yahawashi who's yahawashi Jesus
yeah can we check the similarities huh
let's go through the
similarity okay one one he was savior
one one he was the savior of Israel two
he was a king over Israel was M A Savior
yes
how hold on a second did Jesus
Jesus I'm asking let's talk about human
being come on please allow
it we let you we let you talk we let you
talk mes di for your
sins how is he a savior then please tell
me savior to read the josa a savior as
well josua a savior what does it mean to
be you guys acting like you're so scared
let me finish it let meish let me finish
it
listen work why you also work CU we're
passionate I'm
passionate when's Jesus
married Jesus married hold on a
second I'm not going to talk I'm not
going to talk so you agitated CU that
means you can't answer me okay Jesus
wasn't married Moses was married
Muhammad peace be upon all of them was
married did they wait did Jesus have
children did Jesus have children fam you
see see it's getting to so much you have
to do some you get bad it's cool it's
cool it's cool did Jesus have children
did Jesus have children look he's being
honest Jesus didn't have children
Muhammad and Moses had children how many
people do you think one second was Jesus
belong to a tribe yes no
he Hebrew
verre for it is evidence that our Lord
sprang out of Judah of which
tribe one
second look man that's the end of cut
just got can I finish can I finish okay
can I finish supp support you're still
there you still there the heart is still
be all right did he was he forc IM
migration Sor was he forc Migration by
people like Pharaoh was after Moses
right and the pagans but after Muhammad
he now new laws who brought new laws did
Jesus bring a new law no he said I did
not come to break the law but to fulfill
it but Moses and mhammad mesing yes he
did are you for real come on man you
said you should know this better than
[Music]
me why was it new no it wasn't new it
wasn't no new laws bro them laws existed
even the time okay BR if you look at the
similarities yeah Jesus has got nothing
do with MES what you mean nothing what
you mean look Atari you know I'll just
told you Moses Moses was a savior Moses
was a savior unto the people and Moses
made intercession oh no wait wait Moses
was a savior to the people and Moses
made intercession on behalf of the
people okay Jesus yahawashi did the
exact same thing what do you call Jesus
and he was a king what you call Jesus my
Lord and My Savior My Lord and my savior
right do you say that for Moses huh you
say that for Moses no but he still was
the so that means they are not the same
they not the same they not they not Saed
so Moses didn't save the
Israelites Moses didn't save the
Israelites he did but I'm about
save he saved them from getting killed
Jesus died for your
sinso being different things that's sa
us from being we let the people decide
that's what you we let the people
[Music]
can I see this
book I don't
want I'm not I'm
not ask I'm
I'm
I'm can I can can I say in John 125 they
come up to him and go who are you yeah
and confess then who are you are you
Elijah he says no he says no I'm not he
goes he goes he goes he goes are you the
prophet okay we come we'll come to let
me finish this we'll come to that John's
asking he goes are you the prophet yeah
he goes are you the prophet he goes no
who's he on about when he goes are you
the prophet he doesn't say are you a
prophet
goah he goes I'm not he goes who are you
said that look he goes are you Elijah he
goes no I'm not Elijah yeah yeah yeah
the Christ and the prophet is the same
one hold on the Christ and the prophet
the same not the same
come is the Christ is the Christ
theet listen listen listen guys you're
the same guy that comes with a god with
99 names but but but yahawashi called
Christ and the prophet and the King what
talking about you're a mad man you're a
mad man he CLE I want to ask who is this
Prophet says when when it says are you
the prophet was
yahawashi the Christ was yahawashi the
king the king that was to come was
yahawashi as well
that's man you made
mesor went over theic of that and you
agreed why are you not
agree we agree we agree the Moses of
israelit
yeah was Muhammad is no they come from
the same father among
your so our Breen too are the hamites
are brethen as well are the hamites
listen listen are the hamites are
Brethren as well I don't know what Hite
is I don't
know listen bro our brethen are
Israelites that's Nation a brethen are
those within our nation that's that's
that's you I'm telling you me what I
just read you where the Lord said we
ain't supposed to choose a king that is
not from among our Brethren fam can you
open can you open Isaiah 42 look he look
man look we going through it going
through it you
know might go go to Saints buy all the
wine in the wi and then drink it all and
then like
play that's cuz you're why can't you
drink alcohol why can't you drink alcol
you are you not to drink
alcohol doesn't it say you drink of wine
is a mocker in your Bible are you a mo
it didn't say you can't drink wine it
said exactly it doesn't say you can't
drink you Mo show me it then don't drink
alcohol what you
mean if you drink if you drink alcohol
say you're a mo it's not me he didn't
say that he said wine is a marker that's
why have to get understanding it means
if a guy drinks too much too much right
and he becomes drunk he becomes a mocker
people make mockery of him he didn't say
you can't drink liquor okay it says if
you drink too much that's like if you
drink too much water you'll die that
doesn't mean you can't drink water
you're just being Dr but you can smoke
you
smoke but you smoke all it's like saying
somebody that's in your he's not allowed
to do this but he does so on the
Passover when Jesus drank wine what was
that
juice that's your Bible say I don't
believe that know you don't believe that
because because you can't because the
Bible has nothing to do with you and
Madness man how's it Madness it is
madness in your Bible it talks about
this man who will go and break the idols
and fight the pagans who is this
man hold
second second you said Adam Adam is
yahawashi Moses is
yahawashi before mamad they wor the what
I'm saying is this I didn't swear once
or insult them once this don't [__]
about
man in your Bible doesn't it talk about
people one second doesn't it talk about
people migrating to a valley of Becca in
your Bible what's Becca where Becca
where's
beccaa what is it there hold on a second
cuz in the Quran it says as well so
where is it hold a second where is it I
want I want to check say is this a
coincidence is this a coincidence it
says Becca the valy of Becca where you
migrate to it talks about a man who who
breaks the idols and fights the pagans
to
Meagan man how is
he smashed the idols he smashed all the
idols what what are you talking about
man you worship manist you're mental man
listen you're mental don't you should
answer me with your Bible man you don't
need to find a place where tra really F
jump in front that's you you need to go
jump in cuz
you he me all you're doing is insulting
swearing this time you know what that
means that means you couldn't answer me
and you're like let me let me start
swearing at I've you from day one you
didn't show me show me how our God has a
different name to your god listen what
is names got to do with anything what
got do you still here I'm still here I'm
still here this man said what I'm asking
this who is this man so if I come and I
say
my I'm asking you something who is this
man I just told you that that man is
talking about yahawashi okay is okay is
Adam yahawashi yes okay it's
Moses mes was David it's Solomon okay so
I'm asking you something F how on Earth
he's everywhere bro I don't
understand listen listen laughing and
smiling ain't going to go anywhere let's
come back to the topic let's come back
to the topic this guy is yeah
I'm sorry man I'm sorry
man I am I am in the Bible when it talks
about the unlettered who is this
[Music]
unlet you guys know what I'm talking
about UNL yes UNL doesn't know how to do
[Music]
right okay I'll give the verse give me
the
verse exactly why is your Bible talking
about
you don't know listen bro most of the
people in England don't know how to
be excuses won't help I'm telling you
it's listen when it talks about from the
mount pan where is Mount
Pon One Second where is M me I you I'm
going give I'm going to give I'm going
give you two more vers no no no that one
where's M it's in your Bible in the
Middle East when it says a prophet is
going to come from
there do you don't know your it says be
it says there's three
mountains
why why
you me
here for
hours what's wrong with that what I'm
saying is this it talks about Mount pan
a prophet's going to come it talks about
this Prophet as attacking the pagans and
breaking the idols in your bookter 188
says among your brethren like unto you
mes got and when we compare it when we
compare it Jesus is not like
Moses
[Music]
for